That's good too, that's good.
[Music]
Friends, we're
friends. [Music] That's what I
said.
[Music] I
killed the cow.
[Applause]
[Music] From
that day on, the rabbit
became a carrot rabbit, chasing after delicious carrots.  It's
all because of that kid's
friends, which means
they're not good.
Maybe you're just too extreme. If you like it that much, you
should just pick carrots yourself.
That's impossible. Rabbits only drop plant drops D. They
only drop carrots that don't taste good.
Then  I've got something good, something good It's
not a carrot, so try it.
This is true.
If the plant drop is rank D, it
should have gone up three ranks to A. Try it
[Music]
Try it
[Music]  The
sweetness and crunch are definitely A-
rank.CarrotsAnd the sense of accomplishment that I took by myself is a
plus.Where is this potion sold?Sorry, it's
not sold anywhere, or rather, it's a
special item that only I can get.I made the
rabbit my friend, and
suddenly you...
Usagi was wrong when she said no. My
friends give me good potions and
delicious carrots. It's not my friends, it's me.
Ask me anything, I'll
make you my friend.